[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a este programa de radio
francia internacional y de france 24 hoy
dedicado a las artes escénicas teatro
poesía y luchas políticas con la actriz
chilena laura fuentes matus que además
está a punto de viajar a chile para
participar en el festival santiago
muchísimas gracias laura por estar con
nosotros muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por esta invitación bueno está afincada
en parís desde el 2010 pero mantienen
muchísimos vínculos con con chile y con
latinoamérica la última obra de teatro
que ha montado se llama fragmentos de un
amuleto roto inspirada en la novela de
roberto bolaño el escritor chileno
amuleto un espectáculo realizado junto
al dramaturgo mexicano ángel hernández y
que coprotagoniza usted junto con a la
pianista chilena maría paz a santibáñez
una apuesta que podríamos calificar de
obra de teatro documental no sé si voy
bien encaminada si sé si no hemos
servido del documental de los hechos
reales
existieron el año 68 y que han tenido
eco hasta el día de hoy con las
manifestaciones estudiantiles y por
supuesto como documento vivo la historia
de la misma pianista chilena maría
bastante ibáñez
sí me parece vamos con un extracto de
fragmentos de un amuleto roto y luego
seguimos hablando
llegamos caminar católico 50 años
después
en la ciudad no era muy bien
no había cambiado demasiado
tampoco
había gente que se les hará mostrar
bueno con esta obra viajamos al méxico
de 1968 y la historia de la poeta
uruguaya alzira show se escapó que tuvo
que esconderse en los baños de la
facultad de letras de la unam durante
las protestas estudiantiles y la
represión del ejército pero también está
como nos decía el testimonio de maría
paz santibáñez del atentado que sufrió
durante la dictadura militar de pinochet
es una especie de juego de espejos de
protestas de represiones
la obra comienza con usted que dice
resiliencia su parte de la generación de
la plaga soy chilena y formó parte de la
generación del miedo porque haber
elegido esta temática que ha sido
recurrente por un lado y cuál es su
apuesta específicamente
desde el año 2003 se trabajó con mexico
y recuerdo que mi segunda gira
que el año 2014 llegue a méxico un mes
después de los 43 estudiantes
desaparecidos y me quedo me quedo muy
fuerte
el hecho y empecé a buscar a buscar los
ecos que habían con esos hechos como los
jóvenes mártires que han caído por
manifestaciones estudiantiles y le
propuse a ángel hernández que yo ya
conocía que dirige un festival
fantástico en méxico que se llama teatro
para el fin del mundo de escribir sobre
este sujeto es sobre este tema y él me
dijo estamos muy conectados porque acabo
de terminar una obra que además toma al
autor chileno a bolaño entonces en la
obra de ángel él mezcla los dos
escenarios mezcla el escenario las
manifestaciones estudiantiles sociales
de méxico 68 que fueron un eco para
méxico para américa latina de lo que
ocurrió en francia en mayo 68 entonces
también uno de los países además en ese
momento méxico recibía las olimpiadas
por primera de en américa latina
de alguna manera había que silenciar
este movimiento de silencio con una
matanza de más de 500 personas en la
plaza de tlatelolco en ese momento había
una vocera uruguaya que cuando vio que
los militares allanaban la universidad y
ella entró a la ciudad estudiantil a
pegar manifiestos poéticos y finalmente
se encerró en un baño se protegió pero
se protegió durante 15 días
sobreviviendo tomando agua del baño
estaba comiendo papel y siguiendo
escribiendo la escritura y su
resistencia cuando veo los dos
escenarios y leo la la novela de bolaño
que no conocía
pienso inmediatamente maría bastante
ibáñez nuestro pianista chilena antigua
agregada cultural también que en plena
manifestación en la época de pinochet
recibe un disparo en la cabeza que rozó
sucede es algo de milagros él salvó y
ella si bien había perdido memoria y
movilidad y el pie seguía tocando el
piano entonces esa resistencia no es
útil
de resistencia aquí en nuestro propio
fisio nuestro propio arte las voces los
ecos de las manifestaciones y los
documentos vivos que hoy día tenemos con
nosotros fragmentos de un amuleto roto
tienes también con estos tiempos porque
chile ha sido noticia en los últimos
meses por esa movilización masiva de
jóvenes y de no tan jóvenes- también que
consiguieron algo que se venía
postergando desde hacía muchísimo tiempo
un referéndum para cambiar la
constitución heredada del dictador
augusto pinochet es como si se cerrará
un ciclo y ya no tienen miedo
la juventud chilena la generación
chilena como usted decía en mi obra yo
digo hago parte la generación del miedo
porque es la generación nosotros
crecimos con pinochet
pero se terminó como dictador el año 89
pero sigo como senador vitalicio hasta
su muerte y yo creo que claro chile
despertó fue el eslogan como la
imaginación al poder en los años 88 y
este chilo despertó ya no tiene miedo a
los jóvenes ya no tienen miedo y la
gente se manifiesta y está luchando por
lo que bush por lo que busca por lo que
necesita un país y hoy día lo que
necesita es una nueva constitución en el
mundo cultural chileno también ha
formado parte de esa de esa movilización
de qué manera desde fuera se ha
contribuido porque ha habido muchas
acciones también desde francia así y
nosotros nos constituimos rápidamente
como asamblea y diferentes equipos de
trabajo que apoyaron sobre todo el tema
de derecho humano
tuvimos el apoyo por ejemplo el mismo
teatro chátelet que abrió sus puertas en
enero del año pasado donde muchos
artistas chileno pudieron presentar su
trabajo o exposiciones conversatorios
maría para el piano fue muy generoso
creo que francia es un país muy generoso
con chile un país que acogió a muchos
chilenos en exilio también creo que
tenemos un vínculo muy fuerte muy
profundo y así siempre hemos ido
aportando de diferentes perspectivas a
lo que sucede en chile lo decíamos al
principio usted va a participar en el
festival santiago en santiago de chile
que cumple este año una década y que se
va a celebrar pese a la pandemia en la
organización combina propuestas online
con propuestas presenciales durante 10
días y bueno se adaptarán en función
-claro está- de la evolución de la
pandemia pero es todo un reto para la
cultura para los festivales en estos
tiempos que vivimos para la vida en
general no es todo un reto el poder
organizar este tipo de eventos a pesar
de lo que estamos viviendo
sumamos también la explosión social en
el año 2019 que también generó muchos
cierres de teatro luego la pandemia
cierre de financiamiento de apoyo el
festival santiago un festival que se
constituye del año 2012
la unión hace la fuerza porque
efectivamente muchos artistas gestores
directores se suman para poder crear un
espacio colectivo donde trabajo y con
mucha relación a la comunidad eso lo que
busca santiago en su caso va a impartir
un taller para para actores su
especialidad es el entrenamiento de la
voz y este taller se llama estás
laboratorio la voz para el trabajo del
actor voz poética y política cuán
importante es la voz en la
interpretación total la voz humana es el
sello más particular de cada persona y
yo creo que lo que buscamos con este
taller que está también ligado a
fragmento de un amuleto roto nosotros
vamos a trabajar con los actores
chilenos en una escena que se llama
decálogo dedicado al pueblo chileno y
que habla de la resistencia artística
que el muro vivo del muro de retratos
vivos que resisten la voz es fundamental
o sea creo que en la época de pinochet
yo crecí escuchando que somos la voz de
los que no tienen voz yo creo que es
falso yo creo que toda persona tiene voz
y necesitamos apoyarla para que esa voz
salga a la luz y pueda comunicar pueda
buscar algo que nos preguntábamos con el
equipo de escala en parís es si el
encierro el confinamiento la pandemia
puede modificar la voz nos puede
modificar la voz si nos puede modificar
porque la voz está íntimamente ligado
con las emociones entonces creo que la
pandemia desde ya ha sido un shock un
estado de shock porque todo se ha
cerrado porque nuestra vida social
también se cerró y porque hoy día
estamos en el teletrabajo paralizado
frente a un computador durante todo el
día sin darnos cuenta que tenemos
paralizada la columna es la misma
atención de mano y sobre todo la
angustia como emoción mixta es es como
la emoción que queda y lo he visto estos
últimos meses que me ha tocado entrenar
voces que no son necesariamente de
actores son de personas que vivieron
enfermedad por ejemplo o que han estado
muy en el estrés la cautela de la manda
en la causa de la pandemia por supuesto
porque es no saber lo que pasa mañana no
estamos preparados para no saber lo que
pasa mañana creo que como sociedad no
estamos
preparaos para vivir el día a día
necesitamos sentir que hay una
proyección y cuando no hay esa
proyección y cuando vemos que
culturalmente todo sigue bloqueado no
nos asustamos los actores y no solo los
actores también todos los equipos que
trabajan en obras de teatro y
espectáculos están sobreviviendo a la
pandemia sí por supuesto sobre todo en
chile que no existe un sistema de
seguridad social como como existe aquí
en francia y además cuando se anunció la
primera pandemia de los financiamientos
estatales inmediatamente se bloquearon
se cerraron pésima jugada del gobierno
las personas hoy día los colegas en
chileno se preguntan por ejemplo cuando
he hablado de santiago off que estos
últimos días aquí en parís
inmediatamente salta la pregunta pero si
todo es streaming entonces no es teatro
yo creo que la vida que se ocurre en
américa latina no está frenándose
a cuestionar si pasar en un streaming o
pasar un material de teatro a una
pantalla eso no es teatro yo creo que la
gente es lo que los colegas necesitan
seguir trabajando necesitan seguir
pagando las deudas y esa es la realidad
de chile y yo creo que en ese caso
santiago toma un espacio importante
porque es un contenedor de creación y
eso va a permitir justamente a múltiples
actores gestores artistas en general que
puedan seguir presentando su trabajo
para chile y el exterior y como del
teatro del futuro con las generaciones
de instagramers de de chavales que sólo
utilizan tick tock que son apenas unos
vídeos de unos segundos como el teatro
del futuro con las nuevas generaciones
de ya yo creo que el teatro siempre va a
ser teatro porque necesitamos de la
presencia humana necesitamos estar
frente a un otro ahora
creo que lo que estamos viviendo un
momento también de transición de
vincularnos a un otro oficio como lo
pudimos hacer nosotros acá en parís con
javier laso que trabajó conmigo por
ejemplo participamos en el mes de
noviembre un festival internacional
mexicano que quiso resistir frente a la
pandemia y pasó todo el trabajo online
claro al principio no se cuestiona pero
si es teatro es vivo pero a mí me
encantó vivir ese nuevo esa nueva
comunicación no de servirse también y de
alimentar estas diferentes puntos
combinar y combinar el techno vivencial
que llama se llama viviano bueno pues
muchísimas gracias laura fuentes matus
actriz y profesora de teatro por haber
estado con nosotros les deseamos
muchísimos éxitos muchas gracias por la
invitación y dejó una última invitación
este 21 d
de enero celebramos en el instituto
cervantes la noche de la lectura
entonces hay un taller abierto a la
comunidad amante de la lectura y vamos a
trabajar un texto rayuela de cortázar la
invitación está abierta para todo online
online bueno pues muchísimas gracias
anotado queda y muchas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que nos pueden seguir por internet en
france 24 punto conviene raimundo
puntocom
hasta pronto amigos muchas gracias
[Música]